alexis poulain qui va nous faire part
journaliste fondateur de la revue le
monde moderne avec il va tout de suite
nous faire part de ses premières
impressions sur ce plan de déconfinement
du premier ministre edouard philippe
alexis poulain bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt frange le disait
un école reprise du travail protection
des citoyens
le premier ministre at il été clair avez
vous eu les réponses aux questions vous
posiez certaines oui absolument
déjà et il parle de ouvertement de la
pénurie qui l'y a eu de masques et il
appelle les français à se continuer de
se débrouiller les entreprises à une
collaboration de tous parce qu'on n'a
toujours pas et bien les commandes de
l'état qui sont arrivés donc il doit
falloir faire des masques à la maison
avec des normes afnor c'était la partie
se protéger donc c'est clair le système
d continue il est entérinée même dans
cette stratégie là pour ce qui est des
tests également important de voir que on
parle de 700 mille tests sérologiques
par semaine compte tenu d'une projection
à mille à trois mille nouveaux cas par
jour
après jusqu'au 11 mai et après là encore
à voir si c'est nabeul si les tests pour
être fait avec cette idée des cas
contacts de voir qui a été en contact de
quelqu'un testé positif et donc de
tester tous les gens au contact de cette
personne testée positive donc là c'est
encourageant également
reste à voir la réalisation et puis un
des piliers finalement de ces stratégies
c'est de faire reposer la responsabilité
sur le civisme et le sens de la
responsabilité personnelle de tous les
français donc c'est à eux maintenant de
se responsabiliser d'éviter les
rassemblements de ne pas passer d'un
département à l'autre
il a évoqué l' ascension en disant que
évidemment ce jeudi férié ne devrait pas
être le moment de bouger
au delà des 100 kilomètres de son
domicile et puis une sortie du
confinement
on pourra reprendre des activités en
extérieur tels que le sport une
passeport de contact mais la question
reportée à fin juin pour bien sûr les
restaurants à l'ouverture des
restaurants et puis la progressivité qui
semble être le mot clé de cette
stratégie de déconfinement avec ces
phases de trois semaines qui vont
permettre d'évaluer si les mesures
prises fonctionnent
et si les courbes vont dans le bon sens
et ça ça parait être aussi du bon sens
de pouvoir évaluer
semaine après semaine si on arrive à
faire décroître la courbe virologiques
vous l'avez souligné alexis boule à un
appel au civisme pour les citoyens
français
on sait qu'aujourd'hui six français sur
dix sur dix ne font pas confiance
justement au gouvernement sur ce
déconfinement c'est un selon un dernier
sondage
oddo que ça la posture d'edouard
philippe at-elle été convaincante
aujourd'hui pour les citoyens at il été
entendu selon je ne sais pas ce qu'il
dit c'est encore un plan où tout le
monde va devoir travailler ensemble ce
qui est encourageant c'est de dire qu'on
ne va plus avoir de mesures coercitives
comme c'était le cas avec les
autorisations de sortie donc c'est une
bonne chose que les commerçants aussi
vont être responsables de leur boutique
à savoir qu'ils rentrent qui ne rentrent
pas la question essentielle c'est
l'accès aux mesures de protection au
masque est ce que ce sera facile ou est
ce que comme je le disais ce sera encore
le système d donc oui on peut comprendre
que la confiance était brisée il a
conclu son discours par un appel à la
vertu à l'honnêteté et à la transparence
pour l'avenir de nos enfants
on aurait aimé ça dès le début en fait
ce discours il aurait dû avoir lieu il
ya deux mois tout simplement quand on
prenait conscience de l'ampleur de cette
épidémie en italie et en chine également
et qu'elle était à nos portes et qu'on
avait des cas dans l'oise aux contamines
montjoie bien à ce moment là voilà le
discours voilà les mesures qui auraient
dû être prises
eh bien non à l'époque le gouvernement
était dans l'excès d'insouciance et
ligne de crête a entre excès de prudence
et aix et d'insouciance et bien il a
péché par insouciance et aujourd'hui
après le confinement qui était la
prudence nécessaire pour baisser les
contaminations puisque les projections
parlait de soixante deux mille morts
évitées et bien maintenant il va falloir
faire confiance à tout le monde pour
sortir de ce confinement en bon ordre et
éviter une deuxième bague tant redoutée
alors je vous propose un lexique poulain
d'écouté justement le premier ministre
edouard philippe sur cette question des
masques une question qui a suscité
beaucoup d'interrogations et des barons
l'écoutent depuis que nous sommes
rassurés sur notre capacité à servir les
soignants au sens large en masque
nous incitons l'ensemble des acteurs à
se procurer des masques et les données
des douanes le montre d'ailleurs assez
clairement il rentre bien plus de
masques dans le pays que le gouvernement
n'en commet et croyez moi et en commande
puisque nous recevons près de 100
millions de masques chirurgicaux par
semaine désormais est que nous recevrons
près de 20 millions de masques grand
public lavable à compter du mois de mai
progressivement nous parviendrons à une
situation classique où les français
pourront sans risque de pénurie se
procurer des masques grand public dans
tous les commerces
en attendant il faut que l'état les
collectivités territoriales les
entreprises
l'initiative privée soient
complémentaires et non concurrents
j'invite toutes les entreprises quand
leurs moyens le permettent a veillé à
équiper leurs salariés c'est une
condition elles le savent elles le
disent de la reprise les régions et
l'état mettra en place un appui aux tpe
et aux travailleurs indépendants au delà
des initiatives déjà prises par un
certain nombre de branches ou
d'organisations professionnelles une
plateforme de e-commerce sera mise en
place par la poste à compter du 30 avril
les distribuera à ceux qui en ont besoin
chaque semaine plusieurs millions de
masques grand public et pharmacie et la
grande distribution seront invités à
vendre dans des conduites dans des
conditions que nous définirons avec eux
pour éviter les phénomènes de pénurie
des masques jetables ou lapin alors les
collectivités les entreprises mobilisés
pour distribuer des masques on a aussi
entendu un peu plus tôt edouard philippe
reconnaître une pénurie une pénurie de
masques au début de la crise sanitaire
amo qui n'avait pas été employée
finalement par les membres du
gouvernement ou tout début de cette
épidémie
oui j'ai souligné l'esa absolument clé
de voir bien encore une fois à
retardement deux mois après le premier
ministre
admettre que oui il y avait une pénurie
de masques quand on avait al'inverse
madame busin monsieur véran monsieur
salomon qui niait cette pénurie dans les
débuts de la crise on ne peut plus nier
l'évidence les faits sont cruels oui nos
gouvernements à pêcher il y avait une
rivale oui le gouvernement a menti ses
mensonges étaient là
est ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut
retrouver la confiance après autant de
mensonges et de fable c'est toute la
question c'est aussi je pense l'avenir
politique que des noirs philippe qui est
en jeu dans cette déclaration
c'est bien l'admettre la pénurie mme
fait que le moulin au courant du coup
ils auraient dû en commander beaucoup ça
ne sert à rien d'envoyer des piques aux
commentateurs quand le travail n'a pas
été fait par le par les gouvernants il y
a aussi des questions qui faisait débat
sur l'école faut-il reprendre le 11 mai
pour certains c'était trop risqué il ya
eu aussi cette question de l'application
que 8,19 l'opposition méthodes de gros
doutes sur la mise en place de cette
application finalement le premier
ministre est ce qu'il a entendu ces
derniers jours ces dernières semaines
les interrogations les mécontentements
de l'opposition sur des sujets comme
l'école où l'application convient de 19
l'école qui ne va pas reprendre pour
tout le monde on le rappelle le 11 mai
oui je pense que il y avait une folie en
fait de vouloir s'entêter à tout ouvrir
le 11 mai sachant que les avis
scientifiques que les populations que
personne en fait n'était pourrait que ça
n'avait aucun sens en fait pour la
reprise de l'activité économique
donc c'est une bonne chose c'est une
bonne chose aussi d'admettre que en
l'état on ne peut rien dire de cette
application stop que vides puisque
développement on est stoppé et la
discussion avec les opérateurs est en
cours et donc voter pour quelque chose
qui n'existe pas c'est compliqué donc
c'est une bonne chose aussi qu'un débat
à part soit nécessaire est organisé pour
cette application de tracking deux
choses qui avancent et puis dans son
discours il a rappelé l'importance des
députés qui ne commande pas mes votes et
le fait que le gouvernement indien avait
toujours été présent et répondait et
avait laissé la primeur de ces annonces
à l'assemblée nationale ce qui est alors
qu'ils auraient pu faire une conférence
de presse comme il l'avait fait en
disant que ça avait été fait auparavant
donc on voit que le ton change davantage
d'humilité le besoin aussi je pense pour
edouard philippe et l'exécutif de diluer
la responsabilité et de ne pas paraître
pour les seuls responsables en cas d'
une deuxième vague ou d'un déconfinement
adapté tant que la parade est simple et
bien dillon la responsabilité avec les
députés qui vont pouvoir voter avec
aussi tous les concitoyens qui sont
maintenant
responsable mis en position de
responsabilité de civisme pour assurer
la réussite de ce plan des cantines mans
même si gouvernement n'a pas à assurer
l'approvisionnement en masque même si on
ne sait pas encore où on en est sûr les
tests vous voilà une façon de se
protéger personnellement en fait qui est
assez habile et qui permet de dire voilà
on n'est pas seuls responsables
on va faire ça tous ensemble vous le
soulignez également il ya quelques
instants
il a souligné le rôle aussi des réseaux
pas très sociaux ces derniers jours ces
dernières semaines que chacun commente
est finalement à sa manière comme au
café du commerce il employait le terme
chacun y allait de ses conseils qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette observation
du premier ministre c'est facile mais
enfin quand on a une porte parole comme
si bête ndiaye qui n'est pas la dernière
pour les commentaires façon café du
commerce où des députés la majorité
comme claire o'petit qui ne sont pas
avares non plus des sorties digne d'un
comptoir c'est un peu facile de dire ça
et puis il faudrait être à la hauteur
c'est ce qu'on attendait des gouvernants
je pense que tous les mensonges aussi
ont baptisé la colère la déchéance une
part d'autocritique serait bienvenue une
part d'autocritique que vous avez
entendu ou pas aujourd'hui lors de ce
discours du premier ministre à part sur
la pénurie qui est un aveu puisqu'une
part d'autocritique non j'ai vu un aveu
une remise en scène de l'humidité
nécessaire dans la gestion de cette
crise parce que ce virus reste un
inconnu parce que il va falloir
réévaluer toutes les trois semaines
comme il le disait mais non les
autocritiques ne fait pas partie du
logiciel en marche on irait alors il ya
eu cette idée effectivement de marche
toutes les trois semaines un prochain
point le 7 mai lé déconfinement ça sera
pas forcément le 11 mai prochain
le gouvernement attend beaucoup aussi
des experts dans
ce dossier pour des cons filer le pays
et oui bien sûr et les experts attendent
d'être entendu c'est l'inquiétude qu'on
a vu à la fois les 300 signatures de
l'inserm contre l'application stop
qu'ovide en disant qu'elle était faite
contre en dépit du bon sens mais aussi
le conseil scientifique qui avait rendu
son avis le 20 avril et qui n'avait pas
été entendu par emmanuel macron donc
c'est très bien que le dialogue ne soit
pas qu'un dialogue de façade que cela se
remette en place mais ça pose des
questions sur le fonctionnement de
l'exécutif parce que on a entendu ces
derniers jours
bien des petites rumeurs sur des
dissensions entre edouard philippe et
emmanuel macron il ya même eu un
communiqué plus tôt aujourd'hui pour
dire que tout ça c'était des fables et
qu'il ne fallait pas en tenir compte
mais on voit bien que dans le discours
d'edouard philippe il y avait quelques
piques et néanmoins sur la façon de
faire de l'exécutif qui voulait trop
souvent outrepasser les parlementaires
en l'occurrence ou bien les conseillers
scientifiques donc on peut peut-être
voir aussi là une affirmation d loire
philippe ou bien un chant du cygne en
fonction de la sortie du confinement les
les jours les semaines qui viennent nous
le diront merci beaucoup alexis poulain
d'avoir vécu avec nous
ce plan de déconfinement du premier
ministre